Oh, my gosh, do you look beautiful.
When I first started thinking
about this story,
Felix was a central character in my head,
and I've always been reluctant
to work with Bill
after 'Lost In Translation',
because I feel
people loved him so much in that
and it's too much expectation.
I could never do that again.
But I think if you could just
have more energy
and quicker within the lines.
But now after all these years,
I feel like...
I love working with him.
We'll just go for it
and try something,
and it will be something different.
Stand up.
-Put your arms around me.
-What?
Yuck.
Action!
I have a great trust in her.
I've been really fortunate to work
with people that are really good
and fun, so when they call,
I just go like, "Okay, it's Sofia."
I feel like now that I've known Bill
all these years,
he's a friend and like a big brother who...
not unlike the character,
kind of just sweeps in and...
brings magic and life to the situation,
and so, he's sort of this fairy godfather.
Does my foot smell funny?
Ew!
I'm having more fun
watching her all the time
I mean, she was just a child
when she made this movie,
and she just keeps getting better.
Please wait a little longer before you exit.
Oh, sure.
This movie is personal to me in that
it reflects where I've been living,
and details of parenthood
and struggling with being creative
and trying to find your footing.
And in 'Lost In Translation',
it was a young woman in her 20s
kind of finding herself
and now this is another phase,
and hopefully by the end,
the characters have gotten
something from each other.
We all just want to be loved.
You've got beauty and character,
which is the most important thing
a person can have.